the first Scramble for Africa was when
European colonial powers saw a continent
that was vast rich in minerals and land
and very poorly defended and they rushed
in to carve it up and steal the land the
second was during the Cold War when East
and West were locked in a struggle for
global domination
that's when the Soviet Union backed
Marxist despots all over Africa and the
Americans back to any leader who said
that he was in favor of capitalism the
third wave which is happening right now
is much more benign it's much more about
voluntary exchange about trade and about
the spread of technology it's a new kind
of Scramble for Africa which if handled
well Africans can win the old stereotype
of foreigners in Africa is that they're
only interested in the minerals and not
Africa's people that still sometimes
true and there are still a lot of
corrupt mineral deals going on in Africa
but much more important now is African
people there'll be more Africans in the
world than Chinese people by 2025 it's a
huge market and since they're all living
in independent countries they're in a
much better position than in the past to
negotiate better deals with the outside
world and this has been great for
Africans greater openness to trade an
investment from the outside world is one
of the reasons why Africans two fifths
richer than they were in 2000 of course
the fact that there are fewer Wars and
better macroeconomic policies has also
helped
there's still a big problem with
corruption unaccountable leaders in the
less transparent African countries can
often sign deals with outsiders that
benefit them personally but perhaps not
their country so much the things that
Russia's doing in the Central African
Republic where you have private firms
protecting diamond mines and the
president of that war-torn country are
too many people reminiscent of what
happened in the 19th century at the
height of imperialism the scale of
foreign interest is unprecedented
between 2010 and 2016 320 new embassies
were opened in Africa probably the
largest embassy building boom anywhere
ever turkey alone opened 26 last year
India announced it was going to open 18
military links are spreading to China
alone has ties with 45 African countries
America and France are helping defeat
terrorists in the Sahel oil rich Arab
nations are setting up military bases in
the Gulf and Russia has military deals
with 19 African countries African voters
and watchdog's need to insist on more
transparency in the way that these deals
have done the kind of work that Kenyan
journalists have done to expose scandals
connected to a Chinese railway project
is very encouraging second African
leaders need to think more strategically
China is one country Africa's 54 it's
going to be much harder for them to
drive the right kind of bargains if they
let China negotiate with them
individually behind closed doors
even if African unity is a bit of a
far-off dream at the moment at least you
could see more regional unity which
would be very useful in negotiating
infrastructure projects
[Music]
finally Africans should take what some
of their new friends tell them with a
pinch of salt the Chinese government is
very keen to tell Africans that
democracy is a Western idea and that
development needs a firm hand this may
be music to the ears of some of the
strongmen on the continent but African
voters should not be fooled by it
there's a lot of research out there
suggesting that the African countries
that are more democratic tend to grow
faster and prosper better as the
population gets more educated and moves
into the cities more we're seeing that
they're more critical of governments and
giving the ruling party a lower share of
the vote as African politics grows more
competitive voters will have more clout
and they'll be able to insist on a form
of globalization that works for Africans
and foreigners alike